from a World War II film about a dressed
up corpse to a creepy horror comedy
about a satanic child Netflix has a
whole slew of hidden gems that are just
waiting to be discovered the best
science fiction Tales aren't just about
unsure Futures and alien worlds they
also use new and unfamiliar environments
to point out universal truths about The
Human Condition the script for
advantageous is that kind of story the
film is set in a technologically
advanced New York City of tomorrow where
the Divide between the rich and the poor
is more pronounced than ever as a result
of this class struggle mothers will do
absolutely anything to make sure their
children get an upper hand in life for
Gwen a wealthy cosmetic procedure
salesperson who gets fired right as her
daughter enters an expensive school that
means agreeing to be a test subject for
a painful procedure the procedure
involves having her Consciousness
transferred entirely into a new body
complications arise calling into
question whether or not this new Gwen is
even Gwen at all in its review of
advantageous the magazine of fantasy and
science fiction called the film quiet
and affecting
a young woman named Alice secretly
performs explicit acts as Lola Lola cam
girl extraordinaire though she's willing
to do whatever it takes to rise through
the ranks of popularity on her CD
hosting site Alice is able to keep an
emotional distance from her work that is
until a dark contingent encourages her
to perform a shocking act of violence in
his review of the film Tiber of the
Boston Globe wrote cam plays with both
psychological horror genre tropes and
darker existential themes and its
clear-eyed view of the drab realities of
a cam girl's life is both refreshing and
Ultra creepy
a coming-of-age story about people just
trying to find their place in the world
dumplin boasts a cast led by comedy
Legend Jennifer Aniston and charismatic
star on the rise Danielle McDonald the
latter plays Willow Dean Dixon she
prefers to be called will but her mother
insists on referring to her as dumplin a
supremely confident and witty teenager
dumplin stands up for herself against
bullies who criticize her for her weight
standing up to her mother however is a
lot harder so what better way to
establish herself than competing in her
mother's beloved Miss Teen Blue Bonnet
pageant what initially begins as a
protest against pageants and her mother
soon becomes a celebration of all types
of beauty thus prompting other
overlooked Misfits to join dumplin in
her review of the film Elizabeth
Weitzman of the rap wrote this is a
generous movie and an unrepentant
fantasy at that so it's hard not to meet
it with open-heartedness
operation mincemeat tells a fascinating
and gripping but little-known World War
II Story one so filled with audacious
and foolhardy participants that it's
hard to believe it's real set in 1943
the Allied Forces plan to stop Hitler's
conquest of Europe with a multi-pronged
attack on Sicily a troubling option
because it would ensure Mass casualties
on both sides and so two Elite British
Intelligence Officers come up with a
bizarre scheme known as operation
mincemeat our other deception plans or
strategies designed to confuse the enemy
throm off balance mincemeat on the other
hand is an outright lie with plenty of
help from higher ups and the rank and
file they dress up in abandoned corpse
in a Royal Marines uniform and plant
evidence of a false Allied invasion on
it from there the Intelligence Officers
wait for the axis forces to discover the
dressed up corpse and act accordingly on
the misinformation in his Rave of the
film Jake Wilson of the age wrote
operation mincemeat is a genuine
surprise package it prompts Nostalgia if
not for the war then for an almost
equally distant and era of skillfully
crafted entertainment
after expelling Belgian colonialists in
1960 the Congo declared independence so
in 1961 the United Nations arrived to
help support the newly formed government
U.N peacekeeping troops soon got caught
up in a civil war between the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and the natural
resource heavy secessionist state of
katanga the siege of judithville tells
of a little-known moment in this
seven-day conflict in which three
thousand mercenaries working for mining
companies in katanga attacked the 150
Irish troops serving under the U.N led
by commandant Pat Quinlan the defense
held its ground pushing back the
thousands of attackers while waiting for
reinforcements to arrive the film is a
harrowing high-stakes drama loaded with
military action and almost unbelievable
acts of courage and tactical Brilliance
if you're a fan of War movies The Siege
of jadaville is not to be missed
the fear of turning into one's parents
as they settle into adulthood is an
extremely common worry it's also the
basis for the psychological supernatural
horror film AMA Amanda and her teenage
daughter Chrissy enjoy an idyllic
existence on their Farm hanging out and
tending to bees however everything
changes when the remains of Amanda's
mother arrive from Korea AMA wasn't a
good mom she was cruel and abusive and
it was the reason for a long
estrangement but what remains of her
bodily form literally haunts Amanda as
she quickly evolves into her mother at
her most monstrous and horrific while
critics found the film to be uneven AMA
is still worth a watch the film is
original and quirky while it's
unpredictable plot and character choices
subvert many horror movie cliches
Dolomite is my name may have been a huge
critical success when it was released in
2019 but the movie snubbing by the
academy at that Year's Oscars was
nothing less than scandalous so what's
all the fuss about Dolomite is my name
tells the true story of Rudy Ray Moore
comedian and black exploitation actor
are known for his Dolomite movies the
movie covers Moore's life during the
period right before he became a star
through to when his first film opens in
Los Angeles and Eddie Murphy in a
comeback of sorts does a truly
outstanding job as more according to
screenwriters Scott Alexander and Larry
karazewski Murphy was their only choice
for the role and they wrote the script
with him in mind the three had met way
back in 2003 and bonded over their love
of the real life more and tell him I
want him out of here in 24 hours
[Music]
and 23 of them are already gone Murphy's
co-stars turn in some fine performances
too Wesley Snipes is wonderful playing
the director of dolomite derville Martin
and devine Joy Randolph is tremendous as
Lady Reed Moore's longtime friend in
confidante and then there are the
costumes designed by Oscar winner Ruth e
Carter which are as much the stars of
dolomite as the actors themselves
Swagger thy name is Dolomite written and
directed by Macon Blair I don't feel at
home in this world anymore is a comedy
thriller starring Melanie Linsky and
Elijah Wood the movie is about a woman
recently robbed of a laptop who joins
her Oddball neighbor in trying to track
it down when the police won't do
anything about it they quickly end up in
way over their heads and Mayhem
inevitably ensues Blair's double duty as
writer and director works well here he's
crafted a tight Standalone movie that
feels like a throwback to the sort of
low-budget quirky independent features
that so rarely get attention these days
linsky's performance is Ruth is pretty
terrific too bringing life to the every
woman who has finally had enough and
then there's wood who has in the past
few years excelled at playing the weirdo
and his role as Tony here is no
exception based on Bernard Cornwell's
the Saxon Stories the Netflix series The
Last kingdom is a historical drama about
King Alfred the Great the show Blends
actual events from the 9th century with
fiction in order to tell the story of
Alfred's unification of the Anglo-Saxon
Kingdoms at the outset of the series
this land has been conquered and
captured by the Vikings with only King
Alfred and his Kingdom of Wessex
standing in their way in particular the
last Kingdom follows utread of bebenberg
a noble Saxon who is kidnapped as a
slave and then raised by the Danes
utread is subsequently forced to choose
between the people that raised him in
the land of his birth the last Kingdom
has everything you'd want in a
historical drama covering this time
period brutal fighting great characters
intriguing story lines and some gorgeous
cinematography and all those English
accents well they're just a bonus
Netflix made its first major foray into
original films when it acquired beasts
of no Nation directed by True Detective
bet Carrie fukunaga it tells the
harrowing powerful tale of a West
African child caught in a civil war and
recruited to a rebel militia as a Child
Soldier Idris Elba gives a commanding
and terrifying performance as the
militia leader who orders his soldiers
to perform ever more horrific Acts
another winner from the Netflix table of
original films the fundamentals of
caring takes the Road movie formula and
gives it an offbeat twist
[Music]
[Applause]
Paul Rudd and Craig Roberts team up as
respectively a caretaker and a teen
Afflicted with muscular dystrophy out to
explore the country and themselves while
picking up a hitchhiking Selena Gomez
along the way writer director Robert
Burnett's deaf touch with the material
makes for an enjoyably diverting Journey
it's a story you'll probably feel like
you've heard before a nuclear reactor
goes Haywire after a devastating
earthquake endangering the citizens of a
small South Korean town as various
government officials try to escape the
blame the ordinary folk do their best to
avoid the cataclysmic destruction of the
reactor itself so far so Bland right
well stick around because towards the
end Pandora suddenly transforms into
something so beautiful and touching that
you can't help but wonder if Netflix's
autoplay switched movies without you
noticing the rest of Pandora is decent
enough but that ending is one for the
ages
airplanes are an ideal and almost
infinitely reusable setting for horror
movies after all a passenger jet is a
giant metal box hurtling through the sky
at tremendous and dangerous speeds and
disconnected from the regular world if
there are monsters on a plane it's kind
of hard to run away or call up the
authorities and that's where Blood Red
Sky begins at first it seems like a
standard if extremely intense hijacking
drama but these kinds of films always
have an unlikely Hero on board who saves
the day in this case it's Nadia a German
single mother seemingly suffering from
leukemia who boards a long-haul flight
to New York with her young son Elias
when terrorists violently Take Over
Control of the flight it's Nadia who
fights back and it quickly becomes clear
that her illness isn't cancer rather
it's something akin to a progressive and
aggressive form of vampirism the result
is a bloody good time or as Randy Myers
of the San Jose Mercury News put IT
director co-writer Peter thorwarth
splatters the screen with Gore while
tossing in Surprise delirious
preposterousness and even a few touching
moments it's Grand fun in introspective
and action-packed MMA tale both starring
and directed by Halle Berry Bruce is
something special the Oscar winner plays
Jackie pretty bold Justice a once great
brawler who forfeits a fight and retires
a pariah still emotionally smarting from
her ignominious exit years later she
follows the advice of her boyfriend
manager and agrees to participate in an
underground fight ring that could lead
her back to the top all of this
single-minded focus on career and
winning gets complicated however when
her estranged son reappears on her
doorstep Kevin Maher of the times sums
bruised up by saying the film is rescued
at almost every turn by Barry's Fearless
vanity free turn
coffee and cream is about a clashing
mismatched pair and the film itself is a
clashing mismatched set of movie Styles
all ramming into each other the end
result is full of action comedy and even
heart Ed Helms of the office portrays
incompetent Detroit Police Officer James
Coffey who begins dating single mother
Vanessa much to the consternation of her
12 year old son Kareem to scare off the
kind and doting coffee cream tries to
hire a criminal to intimidate the comp
but winds up in broiling them both in a
massive extremely dangerous conspiracy
involving drug lords and crooked police
officers I know it's hard to believe but
most cops are good people spoken like a
true white mate Guillermo del Toro is a
masterful writer and director
specializing in fantasy and horror and
where those two imaginative genres
intersect a double Oscar winner for his
work on the shape of water Del Toro also
made emerging Classics like Pan's
Labyrinth and Hellboy but in 2015 he
directed A lesser-known Fright Fest
called Crimson Peak a Gothic tale that
didn't get much love when it came out
even still this Haunted House story is
definitely worth watch in 19th century
Victorian England a young American woman
named Edith marries a dashing Sir Thomas
sharp and goes off to live in his
sprawling mansion in the English
Countryside but something doesn't I'd
feel right about the home and Sir
Thomas's creepy sister and when Edith's
abilities to speak with and see the dead
manifest she learns the truth behind her
spooky visions and the family into which
she probably shouldn't have just married
film writer Richard Krause called the
film quote bloody terrifying while Trace
Thurman of Bloody Disgusting said you'll
be mesmerized by what you're seeing on
screen
Supernatural Menace is scary but so is
the Dark Side of daily life not to
mention horrific trauma all those
elements converge in his house the 2020
debut feature from writer director Remy
weeks Bull and real Escape wartime South
Sudan and then take a crowded boat with
other refugees making it from France to
England where they're allowed to stay
and given a rotting house to live in
facing openly racist neighbors and
threats of deportation the couple
attempts to embrace their Newfound
britishness and make a go of The New
Normal unfortunately the house is
inhabited by Pure Evil and eventual
witch sends the duo grasping for their
lives and even reality there's a lot
going on in his house and almost all of
it will provoke some kind of emotional
reaction from viewers Tim Gerson of
screen International rights the film has
much to say about grief guilt
assimilation and the ongoing Refugee
crisis and on top of all that it's also
a niche nerve jangler Robert Daniels and
polygon claims the film Breeze a fresh
voice into the haunted house sub-genre
based on the comic book of the same name
by Charles forsman I am not okay with
this is the story of a 17 year old girl
who is trying to deal with high school
the death of her dad and her newly
discovered superpowers Sydney realizes
that when she has an emotional Outburst
as teenagers are prone to do she's able
to move objects in addition to finding
out she's telekinetic she's also trying
to manage the feeling she has for both
of her friends Dina and Stan can we
please stick together
I'd never leave you Sophia lillis is
terrific in her role as Sydney since her
appearance in 2017's it the young
actress has proven herself in projects
like Gretel and tansel and Uncle Frank
and I am not okay with this is yet
another step in her eyes to stardom this
seven episode Netflix original series is
sure to be easily relatable to anyone
who went through an awkward teenage past
here's a wildly different and
unpredictable movie that merges together
movie genres that often rely so heavily
on tropes that they're overly familiar
and predictable in the shadow of the
moon is part sci-fi movie part mystery
and part serial killer story the film
begins in 1988 when Philadelphia police
officer Thomas Lockhart is desperately
trying to find and stop a prolific
murderer whose victims seem to lose all
of their blood at once they find the
suspect Riot but she evades capture by
Falling to her apparent death Flash
Forward nine years later and Raya is
killing again then another nine years
and more murders occur Thomas becomes
the obsessed detective researching the
case for decades as his quest leads him
down the unexpected crime-fighting path
of time travel Chris Wagner of the New
York Times says in the shadow of the
moon is never less than engaging and
it's just about always clever adherence
of the dystopian sci-fi boom of the
2010s both of the literary and film
version of stuff like The Maze Runner
and The Hunger Games will find a lot to
like in level 16. the action centers
around the students add an extremely
Bleak sedate and colorless residential
girls only boarding school the enrolled
young women are actually more like
prisoners and they've been at this
school since they were infants when they
lived on level zero now as Sophia and
Vivian are 16 years old and live on
level 16 they start to question their
strange lives it's up to Sophia and
Vivian to learn the true nature of their
school and their very existence if they
want to escape film writer Richard
Krause commented on the film saying
mixing elements of social justice horror
and sci-fi level 16 is a genre movie
that delivers both intellectually and
emotionally be careful what you wish for
Knight books subtly suggests because
wishes just might be real or at least
magic is and it's a powerful and
oppressive Source if placed in the wrong
heads Alex is a little kid who loves to
write scary stories until other kids
call him weird for it and he Endeavors
to never write again not long after a
happily Wicked and very stylish witch
traps him in her magical traveling
all-consuming townhouse and orders him
to write her a scary story each night or
she'll kill him Alex teams up with
another of the witch's young captives
Yasmin to survive and finds a way out of
the villain's clutches by defeating the
powerful magic that's all around them
looper's own Matthew Jackson shared his
thoughts on the film sharing it's not
just an effective little family horror
Adventure but an Ode to weird kids
everywhere that's good
really good thanks
horror movies are most effective in
delivering truly visceral and bewildered
responses from audiences when they speak
to deep-seated widespread fears they
become relatable on a deep even
subliminal level and great horror
filmmakers use tropes like ghosts
monsters and other supernatural
phenomena as allegories for what truly
can eat Us Alive that's what's going on
in no one gets out alive a Netflix
original from visual effects Creator
turned first-time feature director
Santiago mengini ambar is an
undocumented immigrant living in a
rundown women-only boarding house in
Cleveland beyond the physical disrepair
there's a bigger creepiness to the place
which becomes clear when the ghosts of
previous borders start to frighten ambar
but since she's living in the U.S
illegally she can't seek out the help of
authorities or find Refuge elsewhere
because she fears deportation no one
gets out alive is A Haunted House story
but it's really about the plight of
recent immigrants trying to survive in a
new new country the old ways is a
haunting Thriller about haunting things
partially in English and partially in
Spanish it's a war movie that blends
traditional and familiar elements of
classic horror movies with Mexican
folklore and tales of Witchcraft Bridget
Callie Canales portrays Christina Lopez
a Mexican-American reporter who heads
back to her hometown near Veracruz on
the Gulf of Mexico to research a story
about the area's many witchy Legends her
information gathering quickly turns from
academic into something much darker and
Hands-On when a collection of local
residents kidnap and hold her against
her will the bruja means to use her
powers to rid Christina of the demon the
group believes possesses her Michael
Talbot Haynes of film threat praised the
old ways as the best exorcism movie
since the Exorcist while Deirdre crimens
of rumorg magazine found it to be an
all-around good and scary movie Red Dot
is an action movie broken down into its
most basic elements it's about two
people in an unfamiliar environment
being chased by an unknown party trying
to kill them for unknown reasons the
film starts out with Nadja and David a
couple expecting a baby but otherwise
disconnected who embark on a hiking
getaway in snowy Northern Sweden after
some awkward and unsettling encounters
with locals Naja and David soon find
themselves desperately trying to survive
brutally violent and surreptitious
attackers eventually the deadly game of
human hunting all makes sense but
viewers will enjoy putting together the
tragic pieces Jade badowski of decider
says Red Dot is quote tense disturbing
and well made Dave Franco is primarily
known as an actor in comedic films like
The Disaster Artist and 21 Jump Street
but as a screenwriter and first-time
director with the rental he shows his
filmmaking Ambitions can Veer to the
Sinister And the tried and true
Hallmarks of Horror
the rental explores the slight
creepiness that can come with
temporarily living in the home of
someone else it also takes the idea to
its darkest depths exploiting the
unsettling feelings of isolation that
can accompany a weekend getaway married
couple Charlie and Michelle along with
dating pair Josh and Mina rent a remote
beach house for a few days but when they
arrive things feel a little off
particularly because someone is spying
on the foursome and slowly carefully
hunting them down and it might not even
be the rude racist property owner when
Lima of Australia's news.com says
delivering solid Thrills and an ugly
portrait of disintegrating relationships
the rental is a clever meld of drama and
horror likewise Susan kamyab of this
chicks flicks called the film a solid
Thriller that subtly goes from
nerve-wracking drama to shocking slasher
the ritual plays off the Lost in the
wood scenario while introducing new and
Innovative elements to the
well-established sub-genre of scary
Forest flicks four old college buddies
seek comfort and connection after the
Unexpected death of a fifth fret they go
out hiking in a rural area in
Scandinavia and encounter ancient poorly
understood and deeply evil forces that
wish them harm the ritual according to
Alan shersel of the Village Voice
achieves a tense and devilish power
leaving you in the dark with these guys
Katie Walsh of the Los Angeles time set
of the film its efficient and highly
effective in its style relying on sound
creepy production design and the men's
own fear and misjudgment to create the
sense of pervasive Dew not much sleep
happens in the sleepover it's a heist
movie and a kidnapping paper with a
Switcheroo in that it's the kids who
need to save the grown-ups it's one of
those movies where tweens get to stay up
all night and go on a Grand Adventure
goofy mother Margot was once an
international Master Thief who quit that
life entered witness protection and
married her dweebie husband Ron the past
comes back to haunt her when her old
team recruits her by way of kidnapping
her and Ron and forces her to help them
steal a precious Crown from a dignitary
your mom is getting cooler by like the
second when Margot and Ron's kids come
home to an empty house they figure out
their mother's secret life and potential
whereabouts and set out to rescue her
with the aid of criminal and spy
gadgetry she left behind small crimes is
a small crime movie about people on the
fringes of society who have seemingly
resigned themselves to life on the edge
it's an inch
engine take on the crime drama genre
Nikolai Koster wildau plays a fallen
from Grace police officer just emerging
from prison after serving six years for
attempted murder he wants to get his
life on track and redeem himself with
his family but they don't want much to
do with him this helps to send him
headlong back into a world of corruption
organized crime casual violence and
other CD elements Mike D'Angelo of the
AV club said if the film came across as
jaded and cynical it might well be hard
to take instead it seems weary and
defeated as if some people are simply
born to fail Netflix definitely knew
what it was doing when it snagged this
little story for a screen adaptation
based on a novella from Stephen King's
full dark no stars Anthology 1922 Stars
Thomas Jane as Wilford James a farmer
living in rural Nebraska During the
period leading up to the Great
Depression money troubles and marital
conflict lead Wilfred to some very dark
places and it just goes to show that
sometimes getting away with a crime is
much worse than getting caught
[Music]
and I've murdered my wife to keep my
home
the only way I was leaving it now would
be in Chains like many of Stephen King's
best works this is a character-driven
horror and strong performances make it a
standout particularly from Jane who
immerses himself in the role so
thoroughly that it's hard to believe
this same miserable hate you and Yokel
is the same Cosmopolitan pretty boy from
the sweetest thing you're never going to
find anyone better than my brother here
he is the greatest and I am sure now
just just look at him chicks freak on
this guy
in 2014 filmmaker Patrick Bryce set out
to answer the question what's the worst
thing that could happen from meeting
someone on Craigslist without spoiling
anything let's just say the answer is
something really bad that's what a
videographer discovers when he goes to
the home of Joseph played by Mark duplos
who also co-wrote and produced the movie
for what's supposed to be a documentary
project what starts out as the ordinary
weirdness of Internet strangers becomes
something much more disturbing
that's speech for us that's that's just
peach fuzz say hello
the result is a movie that more than
lives up to its title
with so many Blockbusters on the big
screen in 2017 you might have missed
some of the smaller adaptations of
Stephen King's Works including this one
based on the 1992 novel of the same name
Gerald's Game centers on a woman who
ends up trapped hadn't cuffed to the bed
at her lake house after her husband has
a heart attack as she struggles to find
a way to escape she's visited by a
series of entities some real some
imagined and some that seem to straddle
the line between this world and the next
[Music]
one of Netflix's original feature films
Gerald's Game was eagerly anticipated by
hardcore King fans but didn't get the
kind of widespread attention merited by
its creativity and star power despite
the obvious challenges of holding down
an entire two-hour film on her own
actress Carla Gugino keeps it riveting
making this the finest horror movie Set
almost entirely out of bed since well
maybe ever unless you count better the
Dead
have you ever had a nightmare that comes
true if so you might be intrigued by the
premise of the film Extinction that's
exactly what happens to Peter who begins
having bad dreams about an invading
force that comes to Earth threatening
the safety of his family and everything
he holds dear little does he know that
these disturbing nightmares would
actually turn out to be premonitions
when he visits a psychiatrist get to the
root of these dreams he encounters
another patient who's been suffering
from the same night terrors and he
begins to wonder if there is something
bigger going on
what if something bad
is coming
and this is like a sign unfortunately
Peter's suspicions proved to be correct
one night spaceships suddenly descend
upon the city and attack Peter and his
wife managed to snag a weapon from one
of the invading soldiers and Peter
utilizes the knowledge from his Visions
to protect his family but his
understanding of what's actually
happening can only get them so far Peter
is about to discover that he was
receiving these Visions for a reason and
when he finds out why the knowledge
turns his life upside down
a sequel to 2010's Skyline which
followed survivors of an alien invasion
of Los Angeles Beyond Skyline explores
another story taking place at the same
time as the original movie in this film
Los Angeles police detective Mark Corley
helps his son Trent get out of jail just
as The Invasion begins Mark and Trent
are estranged but Mark couldn't stand to
leave his son behind as most of the
residents of LA are sucked up into
various spaceships by huge beams of
light Mark leads a group of stray
survivors through the subway tunnels to
the marina hoping to escape somewhere
safe but of course their plan doesn't
work out the way they had hoped when
they finally make it to the marina
they're captured by the alien Flagship
and that's when the real Adventure
begins what's actually happening inside
these ships and what do these creatures
want from human beings Mark is about to
stumble on some truly disturbing answers
in just a few short years director Yeon
sungho's trained to Busan has become a
modern zombie classic with that kind of
pedigree you'd think that his 2018
fantasy superhero mashup psychokinesis
would have made more waves but sadly it
slipped under the current for most
people when a despondent security guard
unknowingly drinks water tainted by some
sort of mystical meteor juice he
suddenly gains the power to move things
around with his mind with his Newfound
abilities he sets out to reconnect with
his estranged daughter while it takes a
while to get going psychokinesis rewards
viewers with an epic finale that makes
the whole journey worthwhile and proves
again the Eon is a skill behind the
camera as he is at riding heartfelt
emotional stories
fashion designer Tom Ford scripted and
directed nocturnal animals a
mind-bending and deeply unsettling
Thriller in which the plot itself Blends
interferes and gets confused with the
story being told by the film's troubled
characters Amy Adams plays Susan an
Unhappily Married Art Gallery owner who
receives a fascinating novel manuscript
called nocturnal animals written by herb
vindictive first husband Edward played
by Jake Gyllenhaal the action in the
film shifts to depict the book A
horrifying story about Tony also
portrayed by Gyllenhaal a man whose car
breaks down in rural Texas just before a
gang of criminals kidnaps his wife and
daughter and leaves him stranded it's up
to detective Bobby andez a strong but
silent type to help Tony exact his
revenge meanwhile back in Susan and
Edward's World viewers learn about the
emotional Devastation that led to the
demise of their marriage Neil Pond of
parade called nocturnal animals and
artsy and grotesquely gorgeous but
hardly an uplifting tale think No
Country for Old Men meet CSI West Texas
by way of 20 Peaks a monster calls might
sound like the name of a horror movie
but it's actually a spielberg-like
fantasy director J.A bayona crustin
allegorio eye-popping film about all too
real and difficult emotions from the
point of view of a child which makes it
all the more heartbreaking a monster
calls is about grief but it's also about
a walking talking tree creature with the
voice of Liam Neeson Connor is 13 and
his mother is dying he's just old enough
to know what's going on but young enough
to have no idea how to cope he can't
turn to his Stern grandmother for help
and his father isn't a big part of his
life an unlikely and impossible Ally
arrives just when Connor needs him he is
the monster a massive sentient you tree
who offers to tell Connor three grand
Tales after that Conor must share his
own stories are wild creatures Conor
O'Malley when you let them lose who
knows what Havoc they may read it's all
a little frightening and also wonderful
and the revelation of where the tree
learned his stories will definitely
leave the viewer misty-eyed which is
rare for a movie about a giant monster
who may on may not be a figment of a
child's imagination
television has been graced with many
reality and game shows that bit a group
of strangers against each other
requiring a vote to eliminate all but
one last standing Champion alliances are
formed but it's ultimately every person
for themselves the provocative and
frightening 2015 film Circle takes the
idea and dubs the stakes considerably 50
strangers or facing execution a place in
a darkened room and made to choose among
themselves which one of them shall get
to walk out alive it's us us what do you
mean
we're choosing who dies the Spas film
Spas 87 minutes fly by as various
unnamed desperate characters
passionately argue and bargain on behalf
of their own futures or time and chances
run out of course they also have to fear
immediate eradication by the wicked
forces holding them in the room if they
so much as move John the four of The
Hollywood Reporter wrote about the film
saying Circle keeps suspense alive
building to a final Tableau that
silently says nearly as much about human
nature as does all the talk leading up
to it
an Elite Squad of secret operatives
hunting down and punishing those who
committed unspeakable acts of Terror
against their Community it's a small
film genre unto itself and a good one at
that among such stories one can find as
much action and drama as cathartic
psychology and shocking real world
history in the same vein of Steven
Spielberg's Munich which told the story
of Israeli musad agents going after the
terrorists who killed athletes at the
1972 Summer Olympics comes operation
finale the film details the early 60s
mission of a team of highly trained top
secret Israeli operatives who traveled
to Argentina in order to bring to
Justice Adolf ayagman he was a
high-ranking Nazi official who
masterminded the logistics of the
Holocaust responsible for the deaths of
millions of Jewish people Oscar Isaac
plays real-life massage agent Peter
Morgan leading the charge against
Eichmann MV Moorhead of Phoenix magazine
called operation finale crisp and
absorbing and satisfying both as a
thriller and as a moral drama
on one level viewers know exactly what
they're getting when they click on a
movie called vampires vs the Bronx we
got vampires in the Bronx it is indeed a
violent tale of creepy bloodsuckers
hailing from Eastern Europe in the
classic vampire movie style but this
time they're in a modern day Urban
setting specifically one of New York
City's five boroughs however vampires vs
the Bronx is so much more than that it's
a socially conscious celebration of
Bronx culture the story of a bunch of
smart and capable kids coming together
to save the day and a deeply satirical
horror comedy the vampiric real estate
agents are the center of the story
represent wealthy individuals and
businesses that want to gentrify older
neighborhoods and a scrappy bunch of
young people have to stop them before
nothing is left and no one is alive
don't go there ma he's a really bad man
of course he is he's in real estate like
many critics Ben Travis of Empire had
positive things to say about vampires
versus the Bronx he called the film a
witty and likable horror comedy that
manages to put stayed to the heart of
some real issues while it tickles your
ribs
based on Joe ballerini's series of
gently spooky kids novels of the same
name the babysitter's guide to Monster
hunting is a family-friendly movie
directed by Rachel talale a filmmaker
best known for her work on Tank Girl and
The Nightmare on Elm Street series
ballerini and talale were the ideal
combo to make what could be a kid's
first horror comedy a dark funny and
twisted take on the 80s classic
Adventures in Babysitting teenage
babysitter Kelly gets a gig looking
after a kid on Halloween night that's a
bummer in and of itself made worse when
the kid is kidnapped by the actual
Boogeyman Kelly has to do her best to
rescue the little guy luckily she's
helped along the way in her fight
against Monsters goblins and Pure Evil
by a secret society of elite and
well-equipped babysitters I hate
babysitter
now minnow of movie mom said the film
delivers gorgeously imagined settings a
great cast and an exciting story that
hits the exact Sweet Spot between funny
scary and scary funny
the best horror movies consist of a lot
more than just a few jump scares and
some terrifying form of Bone chilling
Menace the good ones reflect and comment
upon the everyday things that trouble
human beings little evil is that kind of
movie it's a horror comedy with the
emphasis on comedy about an eager to
please guy who marries a woman who has a
son from a previous marriage he's
desperate to connect with the
inscrutable little guy so his
relationship can Thrive and they can all
come together as a happy family that's a
difficult task as a kid is actually the
spawn of Satan and he's not afraid to
unleash Pure Evil and Terror on his
well-meaning new stepdad and that's
where the horror comes into play that's
him with a creepy hand puppet named
Leroy I'm your stepfather now
yeah okay um we'll just talk later or
whenever you want Amanda Sink of the
Hollywood Outsider perfectly described
the film in one line little evil is The
Omen by way of Sean of the Dead
if you've never watched much Bollywood
it may be hard to tell if Maki is making
fun of those films or comfortably
nestled at the heart of it all the
absurdity feels intentionally cranked to
11 but then again there's also a
distinct possibility that a song and
dance number followed by a Rocky
training montage for a reincarnated fly
is completely normal either way it's
totally worth your time to watch here's
the premise and it's a doozy a fly born
from the soul of a dead man goes on a
Revenge Rampage against the guy who
killed him it's John Wick crossed with A
Bug's Life crossed with uh La La Land
maybe there's a Trippy Ant-Man vibe to
the visuals and exclusive action
sequences all tied into a death match
between a man and well a housefly as far
as hidden gems go this one's like
stumbling across a dead unicorn in the
woods it's Majestic and you just don't
know what the hell to do with it there
seemed to be two camps when it comes to
this Netflix animated film those who
like the original manga hate the movie
and those who haven't read the Manga
generally enjoyed it but levito hates it
when it comes to Fresh takes on the
apocalypse lame has most any other
futuristic Vision beats hands down
that's what makes this film so
intriguing in a seemingly endless
continually growing city that goes for
Miles up down and in either direction
robots have taken to Exterminating
humans but a small band of people have
survived for centuries inside an
invisible shield that keeps the robots
out they don't know why their robots
can't get inside their colony they just
know that going outside means risking
life and Lim at the hands of predatory
robots it's only when a stranger comes
to their town that they realize there
may be a chance to do something about
their predicament and finally stop the
expansion of the city for vision alone
lame is well worth watching is a
live-action version of Fullmetal
Alchemists as good as the anime not even
close but is it cheesy and hilarious and
full of ridiculous moments oh you bet
for newcomers to the whole thing the
story is about two brothers with a
natural inclination for Alchemy to
attempt to bring their mother back to
life things go horribly wrong and one
brother ends up with a soul trapped in a
suit of armor while the other loses an
arm and a leg when they're older they
search for the mythical Philosopher's
Stone in the hopes of restoring their
bodies as far as anime adaptations go
Fullmetal Alchemist is arguably one of
the best out there it doesn't cover the
whole story but it serves as An Origin
tale and works as a self-contained story
that even non-fans can enjoy at least
you can enjoy it if you like
over-the-top action fantasies that's all
this is Maniac is hard to categorize
it's a Darkly comic often surreal and
lightly dystopian miniseries set in a
future world where gadgetry and
pharmaceuticals have rapidly progressed
but a 1980s consumer Tech flavor
permeates the design of day-to-day life
desperate and guilt-ridden Annie and
troubled Rich family Black Sheep Owen
locked down for a heavily controlled
psychological drug trial and a
mysterious Drug Company operated by The
Eccentric Dr James K manta ray manta ray
is literally and explicitly in love with
machinery and lives in the shadow of his
mother Dr Greta manta ray a popular pop
psychologist and best-selling author
that all fuses with Journeys deep into
the minds of Owen and Annie and
sometimes both at once when their
subconscious realities intersect who
live out their deepest fears and
insecurities in Desperate ways such as
an exotic animal Heist and a Lord of the
Rings ask fantasy not only does Ling and
challenging Maniac is visually stunning
psychologically dense and often
surprisingly emotional all at once rim
of the world director Mick G unabashedly
and cheerfully made an 80s style kid
Adventure movie rim of the world mixes
elements of E.T The Goonies and Red Dawn
to create a similarly fun Sci-Fi Action
Movie where teens save the day if you
find yourself alone riding in green
face do not be troubled for you and
Alicia
and you're already dead the simple
irresistible premise four kids arrive at
summer camp just in time for an invasion
of the planet by Wicked aliens with the
well-populated rim of the world Camp
soon abandoned it's up to this ragtag
group of teens who don't quite fit in
elsewhere to come together and thwart
what amounts to the end of the world
they'll have to do it all without adults
computers or much of anything except of
course for bikes Heaven of horror says
of this lightweight diversion this is an
absolute treat for fans of sci-fi
adventure action and monster movies
after bringing so much attention and
accolades to Netflix via his
Unforgettable performance as Sheriff
Hopper on Stranger Things it's no
surprise that David Harbor has free
reign to do whatever he wants at the
streaming Giant and what he wants to do
is a meta sci-fi and horror-laced
mockumentary about his life a
collaboration with Arrested Development
writer John Levenstein the result is a
short special that's a bit hard to
Define
Frankenstein's monsters monster
Frankenstein is based around the mid 70s
made for TV production of the two Man
theatrical version of Frankenstein The
Twist is that Harbor plays his own
father also an actor named David Harbor
as the two generations play both Dr
Frankenstein and his monsters creation
at the same time to round out this
tribute from the younger Harbor to the
fictional older Harbor are clips of the
actor from other vintage fictional
Productions like the crying detective
and the actor's trunk the whole thing
winds up both a love letter to the craft
of acting and an affectionate send-up of
the entire notion playing pretend for a
living Vietnam is home to a quickly
developing movie culture and Industry in
the action thriller Fury teams up two of
its Stars director Lavon kiet and
actress Veronica best known to Western
audiences as Gunner Paige tico in Star
Wars The Last Jedi in Fury une portrays
a former criminal Overlord who now works
as the muscle for a loan shark in the
city of kantho shaking down delinquents
with a shattering of a kneecap or two
that violence comes home to roost when
her daughter Mai is kidnapped and
seemingly sold to Black Market organ
dealers
propelled by equal parts rage guilt and
Love Takes to the Seedy sides of Ho Chi
Minh City to get her daughter back in
one piece Fury is a tight often sparse
ride which includes plenty of Novel set
pieces beautiful cinematography and an
intense motorbike Chase
sometimes the scariest parts of a scary
movie don't come from Monsters or Gore
but from Menace and Dread that's what
propels the precisely paced earthquake
bird based on the novel of the same name
by Susanna Jones Alicia vikander of ex
machina returns to the kind of Moody
unsettling Cinema that made her famous
portraying Lucy a Swedish expatriot who
has settled into a life in 1989 Tokyo
that is repetitive Bland and mundane
it's by Design as she's looking to flee
from and forget past traumas she works
as a translator living alone while
maintaining some low-key friendships and
playing cello in a string quartet one
day Lucy meets teiji a noodle shop
worker and aspiring photographer she
enchants him and lets him make portraits
of her I've never had my picture taken
before
not properly
then I am the first but just when it
seems like her icy veneer is starting to
thaw Lucy's life is interrupted by a
Brash American named Lily who goes
missing and is presumed dead is the
mysterious Lucy responsible either via
conscious act or her status as a tragedy
Magnet or is she merely an unreliable
narrator Gabriel silver of the Detroit
Metro Times said earthquake bird is an
enjoyable neo-noir film with enough
twists and turns to leave you thinking
long after the ending
according to the thoughtful sci-fi movie
IO humanity is doomed to never change
its ways and in the not too distant
future Earth becomes uninhabitable
fortunately scientists have found a new
home for mankind on iO one of Jupiter's
many moons a scientist Named Sam is
among the handful of humans who haven't
made the migration to IO just yet
staying behind to test the water and air
for signs of decreasing toxicity as well
as to raise bees that she hopes could
someday pollinate and help save the
planet's vegetation time is running out
and certain catastrophic events lead Sam
to head with another Survivor Micah to a
shuttle that will take them into space
IO is full of philosophical and mental
tension as these two bear witness to
what could be Earth's final extinctive
whimper but also a newfound hope for the
future Lee Monson of birth movies death
says if you're looking for science
fiction that makes manifest the
anxieties of a Dying World our Dying
World then IO is a good place to start
we weren't ready for this
no matter what warning we got from
people like your father
what if John Wick was more violent more
nihilistic with a gleeful undercurrent
of shock humor and an honest exploration
of the Mental effects of a violent life
that's polar the messy story of one
man's quest to relax and secure his
pension Mass Mickelson the Danish actor
best known for his starring role on the
stylish TV version of Hannibal stars as
Duncan Vizsla a highly effective
assassin forced by his corporate bosses
to retire at age 50 and enjoy his Golden
Ears of course his company plans to kill
him off to avoid funding his payout from
a lovely cabin in Montana Duncan has to
fight off some violent attacks while
also dealing with PTSD and forging a
friendship with a neighbor with demons
of her own
Groundhog Day may seem like a comedy but
it's actually a horror movie seriously a
guy is such a nasty person that the
Universe spontaneously conspires to make
him Shape Up by sticking him in a Time
loop from which he cannot Escape that's
a living nightmare Arc takes Groundhog
Day for the horror movie it is and runs
with it Robbie Amell stars is an
engineer responsible for a
world-changing technology only to find
himself dealing with a home invasion
brought on by Bad Dudes who want his
technology for their own means our
protagonist gets stuck in a Time Loop
forcing him to experience his horrible
situation over and over again until he
can find a way out today
tell me remember when you have to
remember
have you lost a mind
life in an especially dingy and
crime-filled part of London is rough for
Tom a shy and awkward teenager who just
wants to go about his business and maybe
take things to the next level with his
friend Lucy when he goes over to her
apartment to study together he's greeted
by Thugs who have just savagely attacked
Lucy and her brother Tom runs away and
tries to call the police only for the
thugs to shoot him in the head and leave
him for dead the good news he survived
the bad news he wakes up two days after
the attack with bits of his phone stuck
inside his severely damaged Noggin
luckily like some kind of Silicon Valley
Spider-Man the advanced Computing
technology in the phone merges with
Tom's brain to give him super powers
with those great Powers he takes it as
his responsibility to track down the bad
guys who nearly killed Lucy
what if baby driver wasn't a soundtrack
driven action comedy and was instead an
unpredictable intricately plotted
suspense thriller about a getaway driver
having his worst ever day at work that's
the log line for Wheelman which also
feels like the greatest Jason Statham
movie that Statham never made Frank
Grillo portrays the unnamed unflappable
wheel man in a bank heist scheme just
out of prison and in debt to a Boston
crime family everything that could go
wrong does but it's not all that funny
it's stressful enough driving a getaway
car for a robbery that's even more
nerve-wracking for the wheel man when he
gets more or less carjacked by another
band of mysterious criminals much of the
action takes place inside the car and
inside the head of the Wheelman speeding
along from one high pressure situation
to another
James badge Dale plays Klein one of the
smartest people in the world Klein is a
DARPA scientist employed by the U.S
military to develop weapons technology
to use in the ongoing moldovan war in
Eastern Europe he's summoned to the
front lines to consult on some strange
findings captured by one of his best
gadgets hyperspectral goggles it would
seem some troops wearing the goggles
spotted some ghostly figures out in the
wild that tend to kill whatever they
come in contact with before the military
can report to their higher-ups they need
Klein to figure out just what it is so
he goes off into the war zone to stalk
the Beast alongside a special ops team
and a CIA operative what they find is
way worse and more complicated than they
thought possible a harrowing war movie
with elements of District 9 and Predator
thrown in spectral is clever intense and
worth a watch
yes there's a sequel to 2000's Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon and like so many
other revivals of classic properties
it's just hanging out on Netflix Loosely
based on the same crane iron series of
books by Wang dulu as the original
Crouching Tiger Sword of Destiny Builds
on its predecessor's magical combination
of folk tales multifaceted characters
and physically impossible acrobatic
fight scenes Michelle yo returns as
yushu lean fresh out of Exile and locked
in an important battle with the West
Lotus clan for control of the green
Destiny sword directing sword of Destiny
is Wu ping Yoon the martial arts
choreographer on the first Crouching
Tiger and he certainly brings his
prowess for creating gorgeous and
soaring aerial combat sequences
why are period horror films so much
scarier than one set in modern day is it
because the relative ignorance and
brutality of the past adds an extra
element of Terror or are images of
Victorian era londoners and Bleak
clothes living Bleak lives inherently
unsettling probably that although
blood-hungry monsters freaky islands and
blood Cults are scary too fortunately
Apostle possesses all those things set
in 1905 Apostle concerns a man named
Thomas who leaves London for an island
run by a cult that's kidnapped his
sister Thomas poses as a new adherent to
gain favor with the cult members and
their leader in the hopes of rescuing
his sister from them however things get
awfully sticky for Thomas when he
realizes that the cult's teachings
aren't exactly wrong imagine if Little
Shop of Horrors mashed up with the
Wicker man only 10 times as freaky and
you'll get apostle
there's always room for a new twist and
new voices in even the most Trope heavy
film genres take cargo which revives the
zombie movie genre from its funk by
adding New Dimensions of humanity
directors Yolanda ramke and Ben howling
based the film on their 2013 short of
the same name it follows a man named
Andy played by Martin Freeman who with
his wife and infant daughter preserves
himself up in a houseboat along a river
deep in the interior of Australia
following a zombie apocalypse Andy wants
to take the boat upriver to the safety
of military protection his wife wants to
make a supply run eventually Andy heads
out on land with Rosie strapped to his
back fighting off the undead ultimately
cargo is a film about the will to not
just survive but to protect your loved
ones no matter the cost
I am mother the feature debut by writer
director of Grant spotore takes place
after an apocalyptic extinction level
event has wiped out all of humanity
fortunately a repopulation contingency
plans brings into action a robot named
mother activates in a secure lab
facility and raises one of 63 000 human
embryos pre-frozen by scientists should
life ever cease to exist mother then
raises her human daughter helpfully
named daughter through a pleasant
childhood until things get prickly
during the teen years daughter discovers
a living Mouse and wonders if there's
more life beyond her four walls but then
she finds out there really is when an
adult human woman comes knocking at the
facility door I am mother is ultimately
a thrilling chilling and even oddly
touching allegory about Parenthood and
letting go
the wandering Earth is one of the
highest grossing movies of the decade
but most North American movie fans
probably have no idea it even exists it
enjoyed an extremely small release in
the US but earned nearly 700 million
dollars at China's box office the film
is one of that country's first Hollywood
style big budget Blockbuster science
fiction epics in the wandering earth
scientists discover that the sun is
evolving into a red giant meaning that
it's expanding at a rate that will
devour Earth in 100 years and the entire
solar system within 300 years the
globe's government since scientists work
together and come up with a creative
solution ten thousand gigantic jet
engines are installed around the world
propelling the planet out of its orbit
to begin a very long journey to a new
permanent resting spot more than four
light years away things go wrong
relatively early when spaceship earth
gets caught in Jupiter's orbit which
will ensure its eventual destruction if
our heroes can't get the Jets working
again that is comparable to Armageddon
the core and Interstellar the wandering
Earth is a fun and accessible sci-fi
Adventure
filmmakers can use the Limitless tools
and Imagination of Science Fiction to
say something about the world and Stefan
Bristol explores some powerful themes
with CU yesterday Bristol and his
talented young cast combine sci-fi
tropes with brutal social commentary
this time travel Thriller is about the
future and the past but really it's
about the present CJ played by Eden
Duncan Smith is a precocious and Peter
naturally gifted young scientists who
with her best friend and collaborator
Sebastian has constructed a rudimentary
but functional time machine they just
want to go back in time by a day to look
around and then come back so it's not to
Butterfly Effect the past and rewrite
history but CU yesterday is set in the
predominantly African-American Brooklyn
neighborhood of Flatbush and CJ's
brother Calvin is horrifyingly shot down
in the street by the police CJ has to
use her device to go back and attempt to
save her brother's life while battling
against the time loops and complications
she both causes and encounters see you
yesterday is a heartbreaking thoughtful
movie one that's laced with great sci-fi
references as well as the Jamaican
influence that permeates Flatbush
culture don't waste any more time see
this movie